the craziest thing I've ever seen  without a doubt though is a soccer game  in Argentina my wife's from Argentina we  went to spend Christmas there about 11  12 years ago and I say to my uncle well  to her uncle you know hey can we go can  we go to this game and he gets this very  serious look on his face and he's like  [Music]  we can go we can go he says in Spanish  we can go he goes no women no children I  saw why when we went because we had to  get through I think three police  barricades there was temporary fencing  with barbed wire put up I mean it was  just absolute Madness and police with  riot gear outside and if this is the is  the the field  people were sitting here and people were  sitting here kind of like as if in the  two end zones what would be end zones of  our football and there was nobody  sitting in the best seats right because  that was the distance that people could  throw things and hit each other